I want a slightly more substantively
address the Republican primary polling
that's out there right now I got a
handful of emails from people in the
audience nice people like you
um who said you know David I see that
Trump's winning a bunch of polls and
DeSantis is winning a couple this is the
the primary polling of course
does this really matter at this point in
time and that's more or less exactly the
right question that should be asked in
other words the critical questions are
how accurate are presidential primary
polls in March of the year before the
election and secondly is there something
special this time around that might make
polling more or less relevant regardless
of how accurate polling tends to be at
this point in an election cycle so let's
go through this step by step first of
all it Remains the case that Trump is
ahead of DeSantis in most 2024 primary
polling
and the uh higher rated the pollster
generally speaking the more Trump seems
to be winning by we'll look at a couple
of examples here the latest poll is from
Quinnipiac University that's an a-minus
rated pollster a very good pollster they
have Trump plus 11 against DeSantis in a
head-to-head matchup and Trump plus 14
against DeSantis in a multi-way match-up
that trend is holding in basically every
poll which is Trump does better against
DeSantis when there are more options why
well because Nikki Haley takes a little
more from DeSantis than she does from
Trump and Pence takes a little more from
DeSantis than Trump and so what you get
is when you include more candidates
Trump is winning by more morning consult
poll a multi-way poll has Trump plus 24
over to santis that's a B minus rated
pollster and then you have the CNN SSRS
poll that's a c plus rated pollster that
one does have DeSantis plus two against
Trump in a multi-way race it also gives
Pence
which is you know I don't know that I
believe Mike Pence has six percent
support right now but that this is the
whole point of looking at a variety of
polls and then you look at an A minus
rated PPP poll from uh roughly a week
ago
and that one has Trump plus eight in a
head-to-head matchup and Trump plus 18
in a multi-way match-up great so today's
polling Trump generally doing better
than DeSantis the more can that it's
there are the better Trump does fine the
next question is
how accurate
the accurate's not the right word
how reliably does the leader in these
polls in March of the year before the
primary
uh end up actually winning the primary
or to put it another way is it normal
that whoever is leading in March of the
year before ends up being the nominee
and the answer is it's not that common
or put a different way it's pretty
common that whoever's winning at this
point doesn't actually end up winning
I'll give you some examples if you look
at the polling from the Republican
primary in 2016 meaning March of 2015.
Trump was not winning in March of 2015
and he was ultimately the nominee in
2016. Barack Obama was not winning in
March of 2007 but he was eventually the
Democratic nominee in 2008. Rudy
Giuliani was leading in March of 2007 he
was not the 2008 Republican nominee it
was of course the late John McCain so
there are many such examples like this
so the part two of our investigation is
it's really common that winning in March
of the year before doesn't really tell
us who's eventually going to win and
then we get to the third part of the
question
is there something special or different
this time around that might make all of
this stuff very very uh different or
particularly irrelevant and the answer
is yeah sorta it is not typical that you
have running in a contested primary
a candidate who was previously the
president
lost re-election and is then running
again that's not normal and so I'll tell
you right up front I have no idea what
the impact of that would be on the
accuracy of polling data in terms of
being reflective of the eventual outcome
in March of 2023 for a 2004 election so
that in my mind is the full story we've
considered all the factors what is the
polling how much does polling at this
point in time matter and are there
special circumstances affecting this
election the answer being yes that's the
totality of the polling story
and with that context we can now
evaluate future polls
if you're like me and you love The
Nostalgia of enjoying a bowl of cereal
sometimes as an adult check out our
sponsor magic spoon magic spoon is the
breakfast cereal with the crunchy sweet
goodness you love but with zero grams of
sugar more protein and only four to five
net carbs so it's perfect if you're
doing low carb if you're doing keto if
you're like me and you just don't want
to eat a bunch of sugar magic spoon has
delicious flavors to choose from cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter Honey Nut
cinnamon roll birthday cake my favorite
is maple waffle and right now they have
limited edition spring flavors
strawberry milkshake and peaches and
cream sometimes you just feel like
sitting down with a bowl of cereal when
the mood strikes go for something with
plenty of protein
without all the sugar if you don't love
magic spoon as much as I do and our team
does magic spoon will refund all of your
money no questions asked go to
magicspoon.com Pacman create a custom
bundle use the code Pacman for five
dollars off the link is down below